last minute training at bunsfield oil
depot
these armed forces personnel will
deliver fuel from monday the latest
attempt by the government to ease a
shortage of drivers but still leaving
four courts empty what we've seen in the
last few days is trouble in terms of
getting that fuel to the petrol four
courts i think in most parts of the
country it is certainly seeing signs of
stabilization but i think it's also
right as a precaution that the the
government has asked the military to
help as well as drafting in the military
the government has sent out nearly a
million letters to try lure hgv drivers
back into the industry
in a twist that includes many german
nationals in the uk whose licence
happens to allow them to drive lorries
software engineer chris who's never
driven in hgv
doesn't feel ready to help i think it's
almost like a desperation which is a
shame but
my answer would be thank you very much
for inviting me but i i'm not interested
um at this stage it's got a funny side
to it as well because i've as i said
i've never driven an heb
before
across the uk petrol stations are still
struggling but a north-south divide is
emerging the petrol retailers
association says fuel availability is
improving in the midlands the north and
scotland but it's getting worse in
london and the southeast
this petrol station in london had a tank
to deliver fuel just 10 minutes ago and
already the queues are starting to form
it is a picture we're seeing at four
courts across london and the south east
where they're still really struggling to
get deliveries this week's been bad
i managed to fill up on sunday
and
this is the next time i'm filling up so
i've got through six days
but
i haven't been able to go to all the
jobs that i need to go to lost work
because of it yeah i've lost work yeah i
waited in the bp up the road
for like half an hour and then i got
there and it was only diesel so then
i've got three kids in the car
so then i came and waited in this one
for another half an hour the
government's
bringing in the army from monday you
have to bring in i think that's a very
good solution
because we need help a lot of people
here need to go to work there's no fuel
thousands of temporary visas are being
offered to food and poultry drivers in
the lead up to christmas but they can't
start till the end of october until then
it'll be down to around a hundred
military drivers to help keep fuel in
people's tanks
dan whitehead sky news in london